welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and why did Eddie Brock and Venom
transfer over to the MCU before Doctor
Strange's Multiverse spell in Spider-Man
no way home in a year 2024 filled with
Madam Webb Craven and Venom 3 are we
about to learn the secrets of the Marvel
Multiverse from Sony now that the
Multiverse is being depicted as a tree
imagery shared across Sony animation
Marvel live action and Marvel animation
and maybe Sony live action we have to
discuss if there actually have been
conversations across Studios for how to
logically link the sacred timeline and
the web of life and Destiny in this
video I am going to explain what titles
like Madam Webb and Venom 3 are doing to
fix Marvel's broken Multiverse Saga
whether it will help and one little clue
I think we all missed in Madam web's
title design perhaps because we were too
busy taking sips of Ocean Spray okay
it's easy to forget what happened the
last time we were with Eddie Brock and
Venom and Venom Let There Be Carnage in
October 2021 because a lot has happened
since then Spider-Man no way home Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness
morbius quantam Mania Spider-Man across
the spiderverse Loki season 2 all these
movies seem to kind of like reinvent the
rules of how the Multiverse work but I
think we need to go back to that Venom 2
post credit scene because as far as Sony
is concerned it seems like Sony still
has some plan for how all these
Spider-Man adjacent characters are going
to be connected and how they're going to
try to stem it all back to Tom Holland
Peter Parker in the events of Spider-Man
no way home and I think we've actually
been seeing that plan unfold in a
specific way that is aligning with the
MCU but really the tldr of this is I
think Sony and Marvel have both agreed
to depict the Multiverse as a vertically
oriented tree and they have agreed to
represent the spiderverse as a separate
organism living on that tree like a
spiderweb strung between the branches
and the shared theme across both Studios
both sides of the franchise both the
tree and a spider web on that tree is
that all of these characters are
controlled by Destiny and they are
strengthened by their capacity to break
that destined fate okay so let's return
to the post-credit scene of 2021s Venom
Let There Be Carnage you remember Venom
and Eddie are in that hotel room in
Mexico and Venom starts to tell Eddie
this we all have a past Eddie wa you
hiding stuff from me 80 billion light
years of Hive knowledge across universes
would explode your tiny little brain
okay then the room Quakes and there is a
golden light from the sky outside and
the furniture warps into a much nicer
hotel room and on the other side of this
transition both Eddie and Venom are
confused what the hell is that oh that's
a that's just a to what did you do it
wasn't me yes I think we forget that but
Venom thought that that towel folded
beside them to look like a swan was like
a snaky symbiote trying to attack them
so Venom and Eddie are now in the MCU
proper what Kevin feige would call Earth
616 and they see on the TV J Jonah
Jameson's Daily Bugle broadcast about an
unmasked Peter Parker the Cliffhanger at
the end of Spider-Man far from home that
was picked picked up in the First Act of
Spider-Man no way home with everything
that happened in no way home like the
various cameos Doctor Strange's Runes of
cough call spell opening a purple
multiversal rift around the Statue of
Liberty we don't really think too much
about this Venom scene in the hotel room
especially since no way homes post
credit scene showed a drunken Eddie in
Mexico returning to his home universe
and leaving a bit of venom goo behind on
the bar top and the next moves of that
goo and a potential Venom plot or a
black suit of Peter Parker in Spider-Man
4 has really been the focus of all this
since then but we forget that some else
must have happened to get Eddie into the
MCU to begin with because if he was
looking at Peter Parker on the news
there this would have been before Peter
Parker went to go talk to doctor strange
and open up that Rift and Venom
mentioned 80 billion light years of Hive
knowledge across universes referring to
a shared knowledge of Venom symbiotes
across a Multiverse and when they
transferred to the MCU Venom claims that
it was not him who did this something
else brought them to the MCU what was
that well in Spider-Man across the
spiderverse Miguel O'Hara offered a new
understanding of the connection between
the spiderverse and the broader
Multiverse of reality this is
everything this is all of us woven
together in a beautiful Web of Life and
Destiny the spiderverse spiderverse it's
called the arachno humanoid poly
Multiverse now you may remember in this
film aelo Hera refers to the MCU as
earth1 1999999 but to me the whole point
of these nomenclature jokes spiderverse
versus arachno humanoid poly Multiverse
is that characters from different un ver
just of different names for things and
that is okay the important detail is
that Miguel O'Hara displays everything
as an all of reality all of the normal
Multiverse as a glowing blue branch a
visual that back in summer 2023 we had
previously associated with the sacred
timeline that we saw in Loki and in the
quantum Mania mid-credit scene but in
this case just reoriented 90° to look
like a tree and then 5 months later bam
the Loki season 2 finale pulls this
exact pivot Loki takes over the sacred
timeline as the new God of stories and
turns it from a horizontally oriented
Loom into a tree inspired by idril
Marvel animation doubled down on this
visual by making it the final shot of
what if season 2 when the Watcher
unveiled it to Captain Carter according
to what if director Brian Andrews in an
interview with comicbook.com their final
shot of e still actually came together
when they were designing a wild Jack
Kirby influence depiction of the
Multiverse then Marvel Studios corporate
called them and said hey you should
actually depict a tree and Andrew said
that both teams of artists were working
together on the final look of this tree
on a shareed deadline before the visual
would have to go out to the vendors
January can be cold and dreary which
makes it a great time to crawl into a
bon charge infrared sauna blanket bonch
charge is a holistic Wellness brand with
a huge range of evidence-based products
to optimize your life whether you want
to sleep better have more energy or just
de-stress which is where the infrared
sauna blanket comes in Bon charges sauna
blanket raises your heart rate so that
you can burn calories while you relax to
help your body release endorphins and
leave you feeling relaxed and you for it
it's super easy to set up Heats quickly
and so now you can get the same relaxing
benefits you would from a sauna while
reading a book for 40 minutes on your
couch get him
Dar Bon charge's emper Sona blanket has
free shipping worldwide and a 30-day
free trial for you to test it out
risk-free go to bonch charge.com neww
rockstars and use a coupon code nr15 to
save 15% that's b o n c h r
g.com neww rockstars and use coupon code
and R 15 to say 15% another important
detail from Miguel oar's explanation of
Canon events in across spiderverse is
that he included Venom infections within
the arachno humanoid poly Multiverse
which I think was Sony's way of
suggesting that symbiotes in the
Multiverse are part of that spider
Associated Web of Life and Destiny that
their hiive mind is fueled by the same
kind of arachno frequency that powers
what is known as a spider sense that
Spider Sense is a form of precognition
and it is arguably the one truly magical
and Supernatural part of the power sets
of all spider Heroes it's also what they
have in common with Cassandra web Madame
Webb she is a clairvoyant and in the
Madame Webb film she's going to use her
ability to see the future to try to save
these other three spider heroins Julia
Carpenter Maddie Franklin and Ana coron
from Ezekiel Sims who supposedly wants
to kill them it seems like the movie is
going to give Cassie her powers from
some lineage through her mother based on
the exposition from The Madam Webb
trailer that toota Johnson just
absolutely crushed Ezekiel Sims he was
in the Amazon with my mom when she was
researching spiders right before she
died whatever quality this Madam Web
movie ends up having thematically the
idea of Destiny is obviously important
to the story it is really a pretty
similar conflict to the heart of
Spider-Man across the spiderverse a
movie that I think we can all agree is
probably going to end up being a lot
better that Madam Webb ends up being but
think about it Spider-Man across the
spiderverse is really the story of a
dark older Spider-Man who believes some
younger fun spider person or people are
a threat to reality and need to be
removed and in the Madame web trailer we
saw imagery of Cassie looking into the
the future through this spider Webby
animation this is Cassie looking through
the web of life and Destiny from her
point of view she is looking through the
webbing that is strung between the
branches of the Sacred timeline tree
that God of stories Loki is looking and
listening through to keep tabs on his
loved ones whereas Loki has been
established As a caretaker of the
Multiverse in the MCU I believe Madame
Webb is being established As a caretaker
of the spiderverse that lives on the
branches of the MCU so Loki and Madame
Webb parallel figures both cursed with
knowledge so it was not Venom who
brought himself an Eddie to the MCU just
to leave a piece of himself behind so
who was it I believe it was the web of
life and Destiny with Madam Webb either
as a witness to that recruiting or a
guide helping it and a transaction
agreed upon by Loki Venom and Eddie's
brief visit to the MCU was designed to
carry out a cannon event or the
violation to what should have been a
sacred infection by a Venom symbiote
native to that home reality in this case
it's a symbiote From Another Universe
who will be infecting the MCU Peter
Parker why does it need to be from an
alternate universe because part of
Sony's narrative agenda I'm not saying
Marvel Studios and Kevin feige are
totally on board with this but I think
Sony's going to establish this for all
the Marvel titles that they have a hand
in is what I'm going to refer to as the
Miles Morales rule spider heroes are
stronger when they break Cannon and when
they become empowered by influences from
other universes oh this is really a
theme to just like share your resources
to study abroad right Miles Morales is
from Earth 1610 and was bitten by a
spider from Earth 42 and that that is
what makes him a mistake in the eyes of
Miguel O'Hara but I think beyond the
spiderverse is going to prove that that
mistake is actually the one thing that
we all need to do we need to share
resources with other dimensions we need
to get scars and other realities these
kind of incursion handshakes are good
things they make the Multiverse stronger
so that is why I believe the web of life
and Destiny brought Venom to the MCU to
make Peter Parker stronger with a Venom
from a different universe and don't be
surprised if Madam Webb or Venom 3
revisit that purple rift around the
Statue of Liberty from Spider-Man no way
home to explain this because if you look
at the Madam web title logo what is that
there tucked in the M oh only the set
piece that the MCU the spiderverse and
the fox X-Men Universe all have in
common and the symbol to Travelers from
other worlds seeking new homes so if you
take anything from this video the
connective tissue between Madam web and
Venom 3 and the animated spiderverse and
the MCU are trees webs Destiny and the
Statue of Liberty hey speaking of X-Men
new rock stars has begun our 2024 X-Men
stick stick rewatch a weekly breakdown
series from all 13 Fox X-Men films and
the first two are on the channel now
give those a watch and subscribe to all
three channels on the new rockstars
Network follow me at eaos thank you for
watching and I'll see you next time
bye
he